alright a man in Texas was sentenced to
50 years in jail for stealing 1.2
million dollars worth of fajitas
Gilberto Escamilla was a government
employee who had come up with a system
where he was rerouting tortillas or
fajitas rather that were going to a
detention center he worked at and
selling them out of his house on the
side mm-hmm I love the thing that's
great about this is that like he found a
loophole it was a government worker he
was like oh I can place these orders
kind of be the middleman sell them again
is this happening over years and years
one day the delivery guy shows up and
he's like I've got you're like I've got
your hundreds of thousands of dollars
worth of pee he doesn't they're like we
don't surf the heat us here he's like it
was an 800 pound delivery of fajitas it
arrived and he's the guy drivers like I
dropped him off every week and then they
go to this guy and they're like hey man
are you selling fajitas and like just
imagine what he went through his head
like how he did not put a gun in his
mouth the second they came into his
office to ask about the fajitas is a is
an act of is an act of God because it
that is so humiliating then they went to
his house and found how many fajitas uh
it didn't it wasn't clear how many they
found in his house but they found him
they found the fajitas in his
refrigerator and that was the smoking
gun is that he had a bunch of these
before you look alive was it just like
some it wasn't like he'd gone to like
Friday's the night before and took some
home it was like his fridge was packed
with fajitas well he had been it was 1.2
million dollars worth over the course of
nine years so even this like one to live
like one delivery and they've been doing
it for nine years it was 800 pounds
worth he had a car he had a quote that
uh really correct me he said it was
selfish it started small and then got
bigger and out of control
it got to the point where I just
couldn't control it anymore and and I
started thinking like what
happened the fajita started ordering
themselves what are you talking about it
got out of control I couldn't control it
anymore
Greg fajitas are the most seductive of
all foods
that once you start getting truckloads
of fajitas delivered when are you gonna
stop that when are you ever gonna be
like hey no more this you know I mean
and if you can and if you can like keep
them at your house for a while you can
fondle the fajitas and pass them on to a
needy home I think I think he's doing
all right how much he got fifty years
that was the part that is the most
surprising story of this entire thing is
he got fifty years in prison that's he's
a 53 year old man like like what would
happen if it was burritos what have you
gotten like the death sentence you know
like what like if he if he like if he
like I don't know like if it was like a
bigger thing like what did they have
drawn and quartered him or something
like that's an insane sentence okay this
is 50 years okay
burritos is ten that's it tacos tacos
thirty enchiladas answer a lot as you're
going to go into the chair if it's just
rice and beans it's more like a
misdemeanor you know I mean but but
anything anytime you combine you could
you anytime you get sizzling in there
you know what I mean you're getting
fifty it's like chimichangas he'd get
the guillotine chimichangas they
wouldn't even arrest you they would just
start to shoot you're just gonna be like
thanks no one really likes chimichangas
everybody likes Jimmy Jenkins what's the
best Mexican food they're all great I
would want to have to choose one I love
tacos you know I mean I did that does
remind me sweet that Erika sent out last
month where she was just like she said
if there could be if like if there was a
diet somewhere where all you ate was
Mexican food I would lose weight so fast
in every response to her tweet was just
like yeah there's an entire country
where that's the whole bag our last
headline is from Australia where you
just came back from where the government
is in a little hot water has a
controversial policy idea where they
want to get rid of 2 million feral cats
a big time problem in the country and
they're so serious about it that they've
enacted ways to mass murder them by air
dropping poisonous sausages among other
things also shooting trapping in other
ways so there's gonna drop them over the
entire country like the entire country
buster was it like one island or
something where they have too many feral
cats I think there's you know there's
certain areas where the feral cats
they're trying to you know get them into
into one area by dropping the sausages
and then the poison takes them out
because the sauce because the cats the
cats will eliminate all kinds of life
you know they'll take out like birds
that have been in us but only live in
Australia so it's like is a big deal to
keep that population under control but I
think that any time you get a chance to
airdrop poisonous sausages you got to
take you know you got to take it no
matter who's involved but I wouldn't
know like I've been to Australia alright
I've been to all over Australia
different parts there gonna be some
people who eat those sausages there are
stray Lian's hope they saw sausage fall
from the sky they would put it in their
mouths so I've got to wonder like who's
whose plan is this it's the government
and there there's gotta be one guy
behind it who was like what they were
like should we drop enchiladas and he
was like no I mean there's some
beautiful pictures in the New York Times
of like guys in the darkness carrying
guns and dead cats it's a serious
problem I mean they announced this plan
as far back as four or five years ago
but now it they're starting to enact it
I think poisonous sausages like if if
the dot it like there were they're a
little worried also some dogs and foxes
could eat it too how many dogs and foxes
do we need I mean if we're gonna get rid
of the feral cats
isn't there something the cats just eat
that no one else does like catnip like
if you but poison catnip out wouldn't
that do it and why not just walk around
with a gun just shooting shooting every
cat you see target practice like you got
a collar on no well guess what you'll
never wear one I mean that is that is
part of the plan too is trapping and
shooting in and killing them you know
there's there's they have hundreds of
millions or how many
yeah millions of millions not hundreds
of millions with millions of cats
millions of cats and in there especially
you know there in this place Kangaroo
Island and there in some of the less
inhabited areas there's a really a place
in Australia called Kangaroo Island
there's a picture of these men that are
hunting feral cats and Kangaroo Island
which is if that's not a Disney movie I
don't know what is oh my god that would
be a great like animated movie where you
just say you got dropped over the cabin
you game we got dropped on an island and
had to kill a hundred hundred million
cats people hate cats - I mean I love
cats I grew up with with two cats in my
house at all times
if one passed away just got another one
- you know replace them we had a dog I
understand no cats work yeah I'm just
saying but I as I've gotten older I've
realized like there's a lot of adults
especially men who are just very anti
cats and I think would love a video game
like that I mean I don't like the
shedding I don't like the litter box I
would never have one in my place but
feral cats should all be killed feral
cats are are terrible terrible creatures
and they're nothing like regular cats or
they're smarter than the rest of us one
of the reasons why they're dropping
these poisonous sausages is that people
who hunt and trap cats and have been
hired by the government essentially are
convinced that the cats are learn about
it that like if you capture them once
they're too smart to get captured twice
it once shot at you know you get a
couple but then you're never gonna get
him again and the only way to do this is
with the poisonous sausages mm-hmm if
you remember the movie Batman return or
the Dark Knight Alfred the butler tells
a story about hunting a jewel thief in
the jungles and they finally caught him
they just burned the whole jungle down I
think that's what you got to do in
Australia get everyone out of there
light the place up
and then come back when it's cat free
you
[Music]